ils viennent de toute la France pour
célébrer le fromage à melon en Yvelines
et avec 300 variétés différentes il y en
a pour tous les goûts on propose de la
tombe fermière qui est de l'atome de
bâche de jerse au lait Gerz on a
plusieurs affinages on a une médaille
d'argent en Île-de-France et donc on a
l'atome jeune la tomme de printemps
d'hiver la tomme vieille ensuite on a
plusieurs produits frais comme des
yaourts des crèmes dessert crème fraîche
faisselle fromage blanc fromage frais
voilà à peu près on a goûté quelques
fromages moi perso je n'aime pas le de
fromage fort j'aime bien ceux qui sont
un petit peu durs là pas dur donc du
coup le chèvre j'aime bien aussi on a
pris de l'aligot voilà tout ça tout ça
c'est bon mais je préfère ça avec du
paquet j'aime pas les vrais fromages
et pour cette 27e édition ce sont les
Alpes qui sont mises à l'honneur
véritable rendez-vous pour les
professionnels avec une cinquantaine
d'exposants la plupart sont des
affineurs ou des producteurs cette
possibilité de faire connaître nos
produits aux consommateurs d'expliquer
ce qu'on fait d'expliquer nos métiers et
ça c'est un vrai plaisir et cette année
est particulière puisque
Meulan-en-Yvelines a obtenu le label
année de la gastronomie une distinction
qui met en avant les initiatives de
valorisation de la gastronomie sur tout
le territoire on a toujours à peu près
30 000 visiteurs sur tout le week-end
donc un gros succès et puis des
exposants fromage et vins qui viennent
de toute la France donc on est très
contents parce qu'on fidélise nos
exposants et on fidélise aussi nos
visiteurs
et ce sont plus de 300 000 morceaux de
fromage qui sont dégustés chaque année
durant le week-end